una hernia inguinal suele aparecer como
una protuberancia en la parte inferior
del abdomen también llamada ingle o en
el escroto
antes del nacimiento los testículos del
bebé crecen dentro del abdomen y luego
se desplazan al escroto para llegar al
escroto los testículos deben pasar a
través de dos aberturas llamadas anillos
inguinal es interno y externo
y un canal entre ellos llamado conducto
inguinal formado por los músculos de la
pared abdominal
cuando los testículos se entran en el
escroto el tejido que recubre la pared
abdominal viene con ellos formando un
saco
normalmente la abertura del saco hacia
el conducto inguinal se cierra durante
los seis meses posteriores al nacimiento
a veces por motivos desconocidos la
abertura del saco no se cierra
como consecuencia el saco de tejido
abierto puede llenarse con líquido que
normalmente permanece dentro del abdomen
el saco lleno de líquido que rodea el
testículo se llama hidrocele
también puede deslizarse hacia el saco
una pequeña porción del intestino del
bebé o un poco de tejido adiposo del
abdomen lo que da lugar a una hernia
inguinal
por lo general un médico podrá mover
suavemente el intestino de vuelta al
abdomen
sin embargo el intestino puede quedar
atrapado o encarcelado dentro del saco
de tejido tendrá el aspecto de un bulto
duro y sensible y es una urgencia
después de aproximadamente 6 horas el
intestino que está dentro de una hernia
encarcelada puede perder su suministro
de sangre y morir esto se llama hernia
estrangulada y es una urgencia que
requiere atención médica inmediata y
cirugía para repararla
los hidrogeles y las hernias inguinales
requieren una operación para atar y
extirpar el saco de tejido a fin de
evitar futuras hernias y posibles
lesiones en el intestino delgado para
comenzar el cirujano hará una pequeña
incisión cerca de la hernia a
continuación el cirujano se parará con
cuidado el saco de tejido de las
estructuras del cordón incluidos los
vasos sanguíneos pequeños y el conducto
deferente que están unidos al testículo
a continuación el cirujano abrirá el
saco para buscar contenido herniado en
el interior por lo general el saco está
vacío sin embargo el contenido herniado
será desplazado de nuevo hacia el
abdomen
a veces en niños menores de 2 años de
edad
el cirujano insertará un instrumento
llamado laparoscopia a través del saco
de tejido abierto el laparoscopio
contiene una cámara que permitirá al
cirujano mirar el anillo interno por el
otro lado y comprobar si hay una hernia
en ese lado si el otro anillo interno
está abierto y hay una hernia el
cirujano deberá realizar una reparación
similar en ese lado
después de comprobar si hay una hernia
en el otro lado el cirujano atará el
saco de tejido vacío con una sutura el
resto del saco se eliminará
por último el cirujano cerrará la
incisión con suturas solubles adhesivo
cutáneo o vendaje con cinta de cierre
el bebé puede recibir una inyección de
anestesia en la piel cerca de la
incisión como ayuda para controlar el
dolor que se produce después del
procedimiento
para obtener más información sobre la
reparación de la hernia inguinal
pediátrica hablé con su proveedor de
atención médica